wo ist ein
[Musik]
es kommt sehr gerne ist alles in ordnung
ich muss das rennen um nicht zu spät zu
kommen
wir beginnen mit dem unterricht
wir haben heute zwei gäste hier die mit
uns über das thema flucht sprechen
werden
engelhardt und selber al pacino wenn man
zu spät kommt dann sollte man sich
wenigstens entschuldigen schließlich
waren alle anderen hier pünktlich daher
entschuldigung
also beide familien müssen aus ihrer
heimat fliehen du auch wenn ich zu spät
komme dann entschuldige ich mich
findest du es in ordnung dass ich den
unterricht jedes mal wieder unterbrechen
muss das stört alle anschuldigungen
also mir reicht's langsam ja diese
ständige unpünktlichkeit ist absolut
inakzeptabel und überhaupt kein grund
zum grinsen
wenn wir jetzt weitermachen
[Musik]